ce
bienvenue dans le débat sur france 24
consacrait aux discours des mails macron
au parlement européen de strasbourg
alors que le chef de l'état français
préside le conseil européen pendant six
mois emmanuel macron a mis l'accent sur
les valeurs de l'europe démocratie
progrès paix et il souhaite une
actualisation de la charte des droits
fondamentaux notamment sur les questions
de lits vg le président français a
évoqué un nouvel ordre de sécurité de
stabilité et la nécessité d'une europe
puissante qui doit dialoguer avec la
russie at il dit et belle macro a aussi
été questionné par des députés européens
des échanges qui avait un goût de
campagne présidentielle française alors
quelle est la vision de l'europe
d'emmanuel macron comment s'inscrit-elle
dans la présidentielle de quelle europe
par le ton d'une europe des nations ou
d'une europe souveraine et yat-il d'un
côté les eurosceptiques et de l'autre
les pro-européens et puis comment parler
d'une europe puissante alors que les
négociations sur l'ukraine se passe sur
l'europe l'europe et à emmanuel macron
est il seul contre tous on en débat avec
mes invités j'ai le plaisir d'avoir à
mes côtés pierre henri dumont bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes secrétaire général
adjoint et l'air député du pas de calais
et nous avons également avec nous trois
députés européens en direct de
strasbourg tout d'abord sandro gozi donc
députés non c'est là là c'est anna
départ n'est grunberg bonsoir à vous
franco allemande vous êtes députée
européenne les verts alliance libre
européenne donc en direct de strasbourg
avec nous également sandro gozi député
européen la république en marche enfin
le groupe renew comme on dit en europe
sandro gozi et bonsoir et bienvenue à
vous également bonsoir vous lassez pas
l'invitation hervé juvin est avec nous
députés européens rassemblement national
cette fois bonsoir je sais que vous êtes
en train de vous installer donc vous
êtes là dans quelques minutes on va
démarrer par justement un extrait du
discours d' emmanuel macron c'était donc
à strasbourg on le disait et vous allez
voir que le président français il défend
les valeurs de l'europe
cette europe dont je viens de parler
notre construction européenne repose sur
trois grandes promesses
une promesse de démocratie
une promesse
de progrès partagée par tous
et une promesse de paix
elle a tenu ses promesses durant cette
décennie mais le moment que nous visons
par le retour du tragique de l'histoire
et de quelques évidences géographique
l'ébranlement actuelle que nous vivons
vient bousculer ces trois promesses je
pense que le défi qui est le nôtre et de
tâcher d'y répondre pas simplement
d'ailleurs dans les mois qui viennent
au fond la tâche qui est la nôtre est
sans doute celle de notre génération et
de répondre en profondeur à la
refondation
de ses promesses
et je vous vous écoutez tout de suite la
réaction de jarden bord des bordels
bardella pardon députés durs assemblés
nation eurodéputés du rassemblant
rassemblement national je vais y arriver
votre europe à 60 ans la nôtre en à 3000
votre projet politique a pour but
d'effacer les nations d'europe le nôtre
de les sauver il faut déconstruire
l'histoire de france aviez-vous déclaré
on comprend donc votre enthousiasme de
vous retrouver aujourd'hui à la tête
d'une institution qui s'est donné pour
objectif la dissolution de l'europe
millénaire vous et vos alliés avaient
fait de l'europe l'arrière-cour de
washington
la proie de pékin le paillasson
d'erdogan et l'hôtel de l'afrique sandro
gozi je voulais démarrer par vous il y
avait un parfum claire de campagne
française dans l'hémicycle européen à
strasbourg avec ces questions des
députés européens ce que ça vous sembler
normal quoique même inévitable
disons que chaque présidence en exercice
est toujours affecté en paix par un
débat des zones domestiques
disons que je dirais qu'aujourd'hui ils
ont raison vraiment exagéré et certains
interventions de députés français d'un
candidat à la présidence avec oublie
qu'on me yannick jadot d'un grand
soutien à une autre candidate à la
présidence en public comme bardella sont
allés au delà de ce qui est est
acceptable d'asile dans un moment d
grande importance pour l'europe est dans
un moment où il fallait débattre des
grands choix que la france propose aux
européens devaient faire et pas
seulement du grand choix que les
français sont amenés à faire au mois
d'avril donc je crois que pas mal des
lignes rouges ont été dépassés le
président a fait un discours très
européen des grandes idées très haut
niveau les interventions peut être aura
t 1 p cette occasion lorsqu'il parle
d'une dissolution de l'europe jordan
bardella justement quelle est votre
réaction sandro gozi
moi ma réaction c'est celle du président
aujourd'hui mais c'est pas de la a bien
fait en peinant pour tous quoi et
n'importe quoi sur les questions
géopolitiques de dire n'importe quoi sur
les questions migratoires parce que
c'est justement la la la la la la vision
que
emmanuel macron nous apprennent ou dame
nous a proposés et les raisons
fondamentales pour lesquelles nous
voulons refonder l'europe sont justement
celles des données décret est une
puissance européenne et c'est à travers
la position européenne est pas les
retours nationalisme que nous pouvons
protéger nos intérêts promouvoir nos
valeurs face à des états d'aider contino
empire dans les sens disons géopolitique
de termes comme la chine les etats unis
eux mêmes face aux défis de l'afrique
donc justement face à ces défis
géopolitiques que monsieur bardella a
évoqué la réponse est celle de
déconstruire cette souveraineté second
et européennes et paraît pas de
retourner au nationalisme que pour les
européens a toujours signifié à la fin
conflits et guerres et je crois que
c'est exactement là qu'il ya où il ya a
émergé de façon très claire ces clivages
entre européens progressiste
nationalistes dont emmanuel macron
parlent de 2017 et qui aujourd'hui a été
clair devant tout le monde à la lumière
du débat que nous avons nous avons vécu
hervé juvin vous êtes d'accord avec ce
que viennent dire sandro gozi s
qu'effectivement il ya un vrai clivage
entre votre vision de l'europe puisque
ailleurs j'ordonne bardella parle d'une
dissolution de l'europe et la vision d'
emmanuel macron donc à laquelle
s'associe à sandro gozi on sait que
cette fois marine le pen ne veut pas
sortir de l'europe contrairement à il ya
cinq ans il ne veut pas sortir de l'euro
donc elle est justement à cette europe
que vous soutenez
nous l'avons dire entreprises marine le
pen l'a répété dans sa conférence de
presse hier souhaitant une europe des
nations et des libertés une robe qui
respecte l'identité des nations qui fait
la vraie diversité nos plages p 2 europe
et nous pensons que l'union ne sera rien
si elle n'est pas le moyen de la liberté
la souveraineté des nations je ne
participerai pas à cette campagne
présidentielle française qui s'est
arrêtée au parlement européen certaines
interventions à mon semble effectivement
assez déplacé dans ce lieu je dirais
simplement de cordes comme emmanuel
macron veut participer à la refondation
de l'europe pour une refondation il faut
être solide sur ses bases hors des bases
ne sont pas solides il ne peut pas y
avoir de souveraineté européenne parce
que tout simplement il n'y a pas de
peuple op 1 et la souveraineté l'apanage
des peuples emmanuel macron a rendu
hommage à la singularité de l'europe
certes mais s'il y a cinq unités à
sintra dire de l'europe c'est en raison
de l'unité peuplement de l'europe de
plus environ leur 11e siècle et ça veut
dire que si certains sont européens
d'autres ne sont pas européennes enfin
laissez moi rire travaux prétentions
démocratiques de monsieur manama grand
l'état de droit ça cache le gouvernement
des juges et ça casse l'abstention
totale d'une ressource du trajet du lac
celle retenez bien que depuis 2005 et le
non irlandais et français au référendum
pour approuver la constitution et le
traité de lisbonne plus qu'une fois
l'union européenne a aussi demandé aux
européens par le suffrage universel de
ratifier une de ses décisions on est en
apesanteur démocrate démocratique et à
cet égard je pense que l'union oui mais
gravement en danger la démocratie
européenne tian et dumont en parlant de
politique française à strasbourg
monfreid de webber le chef de file du pp
heures le parti de la droite
républicaine a affiché son soutien à
valérie pécresse donc même lui
finalement sa plongée dans l'ambiance
campagne française le dénonce d'ailleurs
à l'instant hervé juvin mais pardon mais
c'est parfaitement normal nous avions
proposé avec les républicains de décaler
la présidence française de six mois
comme l'allemagne l'avait fait il ya de
cela quelques années ça aurait permis
d'éviter de phagocyter la présidence
française du conseil de l'union
européenne par la campagne
présidentielle parce que on va voir
quand voir une présidence du conseil de
l'union qui sera amoindrie amoindri
parce que déjà il y aura pas de
dimension parlementaire parce que
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat avons
arrêté de siéger à partir du mois de fin
février donc juste de fin février à juin
alors qu'on sait que la dimension
parlementaire c'est extrêmement
important il y aura absolument rien qui
va se passer et puis on va créer me
trouver dans une situation où
potentiellement celui qui a fixé les
priorités de la pf ne sera pas forcément
celui ou celle qui valent à terminer
donc emmanuel macron a décidé
unilatéralement pour en faire un
argument de campagne politique pour ça
quand même et leurs enfants voient bien
ce qu'elles intéressent les français
avec mais finalement est-ce mais c'est
vers l'est dans la campagne mais c'est
lent c'est bien vu et c'est à traduire
ça puisque l'europe intéressent les
français qu'en effet
votre interlocuteur monsieur juin a
raison de dire qu'il ya peut-être une
question de déficit démocratique en une
impression de déficit démocratique en
europe et quelle meilleure expression ça
aurait été de dire que on décide nous
peuple français des lignes défendues par
le futur président de la france lors de
l'élection présidentielle qui a lieu en
avril pour que celui ou celle qui sera
élue pour aller porter avec la
légitimité démocratique d'une élection
qui a lieu quelques semaines auparavant
devant l'ensemble de ses collègues au
sein du conseil sort était profondément
puissant et serez pu permettre de mettre
en avant les vrais étable besoin les
faire avoir des vraies avancées à
l'union européenne et à la france alors
que là on est sur une présidence
chancelante qui se terminent champions
parce que c'est la farce car n'avions
pas ce que parce que c'est la fin et
parce que une fois plus celui qui
commence le présidence française ne sera
peut-être pas dans ce cas je l'espère
celui qui va la terminer et ça pose un
vrai sujet à la de parme et greenberg
vous appartenez au vert mais vous êtes
aussi franco-allemande donc c'est
intéressant d'avoir votre vision de ce
climat de campagne présidentielle
française qu'en avez-vous pensé dans cet
hémicycle à strasbourg c'était
inévitable vous vous dites ou c'était
trop comme vient de le dire hervé juvin
c'était légitime
mais moi je pense qu'en fait elle quand
même une grande confusion anormalement
justement les états-nations vienne et
vienne présenter ce qu'ils vont proposer
pour l'europe donc six mois de travail à
fond sur les dossiers alors là on a un
peu un décalage on a un énorme programme
a présenté le gouvernement français avec
beaucoup de choses très ambitieuse et on
a par exemple justement seulement deux
ou trois mois à réaliser tout ça parce
que oui le gouvernement français
emmanuel à coulon est obligé de se
mettre en retrait donc en fait c'est un
énorme programme pour une mini
présidence en temps et c'est vrai il
aurait été plus européen vraiment de se
mettre au service de l'europe après les
campagnes et après les possibles
changements en france pour travailler
pour l'europe donc on peut se poser la
question si emmanuel macron n'a pas
l'utilisent pas en fait toute la
communication et les relations publiques
et les belles images pour se mettre pro
européen devant les français alors
qu'enfin il aurait été plus européen de
décaler la présidence française de
l'union européenne alors on va voir que
cette présidence francs or au pn est en
pleine campagne française y compris dans
l'hexagone puisque eric zemmour était à
calais pendant qu emmanuel macron était
à strasbourg il a parlé lui d'europe
aussi on va l'écouter tout de suite
c'est le symbole évidemment de
d'abord du traité de schengen qui ne
fonctionne pas c'est le symbole d'une
immigration folle qui détruit tout sur
son passage c'est le le symbole d'une
europe qui a complètement renoncé à se
protéger des invasions migratoires
sandro gozi à vous l'avez entendu eric
zemmour qui dit que l'europe a renoncé
de se protéger d'une invasion migratoire
alors c'est vrai que et même accro à
parler de réformer schengen mais est-ce
qu'il va d'abord réussir et quel est le
projet exactement d'abord mal même accro
à parler d en présenter une vision qui
est la sienne depuis 2007 et cette
présidence française de l'union
européenne a été préparée d'épidémie 17
et sur la vision d' emmanuel macron les
français sont exprimés en 2017 la france
a déjà eu une présidence française de
l'union européenne pendant une campagne
électorale en 95 je me souviens pas
l'époque les les représentants de la
droite française se plaindre des saints
donc toutes ces polémiques sont
absolument inutile aujourd'hui la
présenter une vision il a présenté sa
vision que les français connaissent bien
et que les européens commencent à bien
connaître apprécier et la présentait
aussi des priorités sur lesquelles on
veut avancer pendant la présidence
française mais réformer schengen ça veut
d'abord dire et former les grilles
d'asile est une de ses priorités c'est
la réforme de schengen et plus en plus
en général finalement avancé sur une
véritable politique européenne efficace
des l'asile et de la gestion des
frontières externes ça c'est les les
avancées qu'ont sur lesquelles on va
travailler pendant la présence française
donc renforcer la gestion des frontières
excès externe avec plus de à voir
également les contrôles c'est ce que
voulait dire avec tous ces contrôles
avec des procédures d'assises plus
efficace avec les européens qui font
ressentir ensemble leur poids vis-à-vis
des pays d'origine pour avoir des
retours décès qui n'ont pas le droit à
rester sur le sol européen et des
retours d'aller pédaler pays d'origine
ça c'est un dossier très concrets comme
les dossiers numériques sur lesquels
sous lesquels nous sommes déjà en train
de travailler au parlement européen et
sur lesquels les conseils va travailler
sous présidence française ait fait quoi
que sur cet aspect là des frontières
externes et des règles d'asile plus
efficace on peut avancer c'est un
dossier les plus difficiles mais c'est
un dossier sur lequel la france va
mettre sous tout son poids et nous
parlâmes european nous serons à côté de
la france pour avancer en fin juin
marine le pen elle propose carrément de
suspendre schengen en quoi finalement ce
que vous proposez se distingue-t-il de
ce que propose eric zemmour convient
d'entendre
regrette un peu plus grand talent d'eric
zemmour le porte aux extrêmes pour ma
part je pense que tout ce qui est
excessif est insignifiant
eric zemmour envoie des mots que pour ma
part je n'emploierai pas je pense pour
répondre à votre question que la remise
en cause de l'espace schengen dépend
pour beaucoup de la manière dont l'union
européenne va tenir les frontières
extérieures de l'europe
soyons clairs ya par d'union des nations
européennes ya pas grand marché
intérieur il n'y a pas d'état de droit
de rock / ne tient pas les frontières
extérieures
ce que je répondrai tout simplement à
votre question c'est que l'accès à la
citoyenneté les règles d'accès au
territoire c'est un privilège de la
souveraineté nationale et donc il n'est
pas question pour nous nous n'acceptons
pas qu'une union européenne orson
sortie des nations qui la composent
décide de répartir les migrants
notamment ceux qui sont en situation
irrégulière dans les pays de son choix
le fait d'admettre des migrants et
j'admets parfaitement que des situations
économiques que des situations
politiques comment donations aux
rebelles par solidarité d'accepter des
migrants mais je refuse et nous refusons
que l'union européenne procède de
manière autoritaire centralisée
bureaucratique à la répartition des
migrants dans des pays qui pour des
raisons diverses ne se répare les amis
vous à contre les quotas c'est ce que
vous dites en fait
les partitions bureaucratique et
centralisée de l'union européenne qui
entend et au rire en hameaux qu'est ce
qui vous distingue donc de eric zemmour
c'est juste une question de langage ce
que vous venez de dire ou sur cette
question iranienne est plus une question
de langage l'union européenne les
nations européennes
s'enorgueillissent à juste titre d'une
tradition d'accueil elles ont su
accueillir les pipoles elles sont su
accueillir des dizaines de milliers de
réfugiés politiques qui réellement été
menacés réellement et de persécuter dans
leur vie et dans sur leur territoire
d'origine ça ne veut absolument pas dire
que ces réfugiés soit identique aux
migrants économiques pour la plupart
simplement de prestations sociales et en
chef de conditions de solidarité des
tournées c'est probablement un point de
différence avec eric zemmour oui nous
devons conserver les traditions
d'accueil des réfugiés politiques oui
nous ne reprenne les nations européennes
va rester une terre d'accueil pour ceux
qui sont persécutés pour leurs opinions
pour leur religion pour leurs moeurs sur
leur territoire d'origine non l'union
européenne ne veut pas s'ouvrir à tous
les vents vérifier car on est du monde
finalement vous êtes vous en désaccord
avec ce que vient de dire hervé juvin
sur la politique de schengen valérie
pécresse elle elle évoque une passoire
c'est ce qu'elle a évoquée vous étiez
avec elle en grèce
zemmour évoque une invasion
la réalité c'est quoi c'est que ceux qui
décident aujourd'hui de qui rentre en
europe se sont pas les états ni même
l'union européenne ce sont les passeurs
et que donc est aujourd'hui nécessaire
de faire en sorte que ceux qui arrivent
en europe arrive dans chacun des pays
membres de l'union européenne soit
désirée par les pays qui sont les
réceptacles de cette immigration donc la
réforme à shangai proposé la réunion en
mai la réforme de schengen monsieur
monsieur mozilla du tout ça fait cinq
ans qu'emmanuel maquereau en parle quels
sont les résultats d' emmanuel macron
rien comment est ce qu'on peut penser
que les cinq prochaines années manuel
macron réussira à faire ce qu'il n'a pas
su faire en cinq ans la réalité c'est
quoi c'est que quand emmanuel macron
tape sur les polonais ou sur les
hongrois en disant c'est pas bien vous
avez mis des barbelés vous avez mis des
grillages aux frontières extérieures de
l'europe la réalité c'est que c'est ce
qui est demandé dans schengen ce qui est
vendu dans schengen aujourd'hui on vous
vous appelez donc on met des murs bah
moi je suis pour qu'on mette des murs à
l'extérieur à la frontières extérieures
de l'europe c'est à dire que l'union
européenne soit très simplement une
union européenne où l'on peut rentrer
que dans certains endroits les aéroports
les portes sur les territoires
continentaux parce que si on met pas des
murs aux frontières extérieures de
l'europe on mettra des murs à
l'intérieur de l'union européenne est
d'ailleurs quelle a été la réaction
quand les vagues d'immigration sont
arrivés depuis les troubles au
moyen-orient la première des réactions
sap a été de fermer les frontières
extérieures c'est de fermer les
frontières intérieures c'était de
remettre des contrôles à la frontière
entre la france et l'italie ils y sont
toujours c'était de remettre des
contrôles entre la france et l'espagne
moi je préfère très clairement qu'on
applique schengen tel qu'il est écrit
aujourd'hui on pas suspension comme le
propose la chine gagne commençons déjà
par l'appliquer et une fois plus si on
veut avoir un nouveau schengen il faut
que tout le monde soit d'accord est ce
que vous croyez sérieusement ce
quelqu'un on tourne à table ou en vision
peut sincèrement penser qu'on va réussir
à mettre d'accord la pologne or ban en
hongrie la france l'italie et l'espagne
qui ont des problématiques totalement
différente alors moi je préfère qu'on
ait des systèmes comme on l'a vu en
grèce avec valérie pécresse où on était
vendredi où il y à un contrôle de tout
ce qui arrive sur le continent européen
l'an particulier dans les îles avec les
racks pour être avec des hotspots maison
et existe déjà un pardonnez-moi
n'ont-ils exquise un il n'existe pas
deux c'est une nouvelle création qui a
pu bête permis parce que le gouvernement
grec qui est un gouvernement de droite
ppe a mis en place des mesures qui sont
extrêmement volontariste avec le soutien
de l'union européenne pour prendre les
empreintes enregistrés chaque personne
qui rentre dans l'union européenne parce
qu'il ya aussi excusez moi du peu mais
un petit enjeu de sécurité intérieure
var de terrorisme parce que il y a
malheureusement on a eu des précédents
en particulier en 2015 en france avec
des vagues migratoires qui n'ont pas été
contrôlés qui ont pu conduire à
l'infiltration de personnes qui ensuite
ont commis des attentats ce sont des
choses qu'on peut pas tolérer qu'on ne
peut pas accepter et une fois de plus si
on ne contrôle pas les frontières
extérieures de l'union européenne on va
se retrouver avec des murs à l'intérieur
de l'union européenne et voilà j'ai du
mal à voir la différence entre votre
programme et se démêlent macron sur cet
aspect là parce que le duel macron le
met pas en place une fois plus pardon
donc c'est parce qu'il ne met pas en
place mais l'idée est là mais dire que
emmanuel les idées vous savez ça ça ne
permet pas de pouvoir avoir une union
européenne qui fonctionne et qui permet
aux habitants aux citoyens de l'union
européenne et des pays membres de
l'union européenne de penser qu'ils sont
protégés de penser qu'ils sont sécurisés
nous on préfère une europe qui
fonctionne qui fait ce qu'elle dit
plutôt qu'une europe qui palabrent comme
le fait daniel mach rond comme il a
refait aujourd'hui comme il le fait
depuis cinq ans avec zéro résultat vous
fois plus le meilleur exemple c'est ce
qu'a fait mitsou cathy ce premier
ministre grec dans les îles et en
particulier à samos où on était à savoir
la création d'un véritable os x tous
ceux qui arrivent sont
enregistrés les empreintes sont prises
et ceux qui n'ont pas vocation à rester
en grèce ou en union européenne sont
renvoyés en turquie sandro gozi vous
réagissez avant que je fasse justement
qu'on écoute et yannick jadot j'espère
que quelqu'un a expliqué à valérie
pécresse et aux gens qui
l'accompagnaient que c'est qu'elle a vu
en grèce c'est un projet pilote de
l'union européenne
justement anticipe c'est que nous
proposons de faire au niveau de schengen
c'est exactement cela ce n'est pas une
invention du pp ce n'est pas une
invention du grognement grecque c'est un
projet pilote dans lequel vous montrer
qu'on peut gérer différemment les
frontières externes de l'union
européenne avec un engagement réel
véritable de l'union européenne au
niveau du budget au niveau du soutien
politique c'est au petit c'est que nous
voulons faire à travers la réforme de
schengen et j'ai quoi que les polonais
qui pensaient que comme il n'était pas
sous la méditerranée une on n'aurait
jamais connu des crises migratoires
maintenant avec ce qui s'est passé en
biélorussie et d'ukraine ont compris
qu'ils doivent jouer les jeux et
aujourd'hui il ya des conditions
politiques de l'union européenne pour
trouver un accord au moins sur la
question des règles d'asile plus
uniforme et gestion des frontières est
un peu efficace il ya des conditions
qu'ils n'avaient pas il y a deux trois
quatre voire cinq ans et la coopération
entre la présidence française et la
présidence tchèque et suédoise qui sont
3 go en amont qui ont des positions
plutôt différente sur l'asile et
l'immigration parce que la république
tchèque ça fait partie du groupe de
visegrad donc les alliés historiques d
or bas et des polonais les fêtes que ils
travaillent main dans la main avec les
personnes françaises pour amortir sur
ces dossiers et lé signal elle est signe
que la stratégie d' emmanuel macron là
dessus est la bonne c'est un dossier
hyper compliqué mais c'est un dossier
sur lequel de ce point de vue on peut
avancer et c'est que les républicains
ont dit on découverte du projet pilote
de l'europe en grèce en vue c'est sec et
certainement nous voulons faire à
l'échelle européenne alors on va écouter
yannick jadot parce qu'on va passer
justement au thème du climat voilà ce
qu'il a il alpaguer mail macron
l'écoutent
vous resterez dans l'histoire monsieur
le président de la république le
président de l'inaction climatique
parce qu'au fond vous êtes un climato
arrangeant vous préféré signer d
armistice avec les lobbys plutôt que de
mener la guerre contre le dérèglement
climatique
vous préférez
procrastiner tel mery streep dans le
film don't look up
reporter renoncer
fantasmer sur des solutions dans dix
quinze ou vingt ans
anna deparnay greenberg sais pas si vous
avez vu dans le look up avec meryl
streep qui effectivement un quart d'un
président qui ressemble un petit peu
à donald trump si je puis dire est ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec yannick
jadot avec ce qu'il a dit est ce que
finalement le climat et macron c'est
vraiment rien à voir
alors peut-être que je oui je peux
confirmer on a vu des grands espoirs au
début de la présidence de monsieur mac
ou qu'ils avaient quand même apparemment
mis le thème des ressources du climat et
de l'environnement en avant on a vu au
fur et à mesure de sa présidence que
c'est devenu de moins en moins et je
dirais que là le point le plus le plus
sensible aussi en europe et là je trouve
que c'est ma qu'on n'est pas très
européen c'est que pendant que le
nouveau gouvernement allemand s'est mis
en place
il a forcé il a fait des majorité pour
faire passer le nucléaire comme comme
énergies vertes comme énergies du futur
alors ça c'est quelque chose quand on
sait la sensibilité de ce thème de
l'allemagne c'est vraiment quand même un
affront et nous savons très bien que
nous n'allons pas pouvoir régler nos
problèmes énergétiques en allant vers le
nucléaire et au lieu d'aller à fond dans
les énergies renouvelables nous avons là
vraiment lent serment qui revient à
grand-pas nous sommes très déçus vous
êtes très déçu alors que pardonnez-moi
mais l'allemagne il me semble qu'elle a
obtenu en échange que le gaz soit
également considérée comme une énergie
verte est ce que ça ça n'arrange pas les
allemands quand le nucléaire énergie
verte arrange les français pas du tout
moi je ne suis pas satisfait du tout de
cela bien sûr que nous avons des fois
besoin de certains d énergie de
transition mais ça veut pas dire que
nous les déclarons écologique et pour
l'avenir est là il s'agit de de flécher
les nouveaux moyens qui veulent aller
vers l'avenir vers les nouvelles
technologies et qui ne freine pas la
transition est donc en fait ni le gaz ni
le nucléaire dans la place dans cette
taxonomie des finances verte pour
l'avenir et nous nous sommes vraiment
déçus du fait que pendant le
gouvernement allemand le nouveau s'est
mis en place il ya eu 7 ces accords fait
en arrière-plan de la commission
européenne pour proposer cette taxonomie
c'est très décevant et surtout ça ne
nous fait pas avancer pour le climat
alors qu'on a un grand chemin à faire
hervé juvin et marine le pen parle
également du climat mais vous vous êtes
aussi très pro nucléaire me semble-t-il
au rassemblement national
oui je dirais d'abord la déception d'un
discours de yannick jadot qui était un
discours de campagne présidentielle
française beaucoup plus qu'un discours
au parlement européen alors que je pense
que l'occasion était bonne effectivement
pour parler d'écologie pour parler des
vrais enjeux environnementaux qui sont
au moins autant là ils mènent que le
sport échauffement thématique de
répondre à votre question très
clairement le nucléaire est une énergie
décarbonée c'est une énergie qui offrent
de l'avenir et qui offre un atout
compétitif à la france nous en avons
bien besoin pour nos énergies nous avons
bien pour notre industrie est très
clairement ce sont les choix allemand
qui sont des choix aberrants en matière
de tout renouvelable qui sont en train
de mettre une pagaille monstre dans
l'europe de l'énergie qui sont en train
de provoquer la précarité énergétique
pour des millions de ménages et donc
très berland je crois que la france et
ses alliés doivent employer tous les
moyens pour que l'allemagne sans sa
trajectoire elle est totalement
irresponsable et en plus je dirais à la
représentante des verts attention à une
écologie punitive si le meilleur moyen
de mettre les citoyens européens entre
l'écologie et de refaire passer à côté
des sciences environnementales qui sont
de vraies différences nous a sauvés et
henri dumont même chose d'aller ipcress
soutient le nucléaire on a la pression
là on voit bien avec justement une
eurodéputée allemande qui a une vraie
divergence de vue entre les verts en
allemagne et le nucléaire français là on
peut dire que quoi pécresse le pen
macron c'est la même chose c'est le
choix du nucléaire nous en tout cas on a
toujours été pour le nucléaire emmanuel
macron c'est peut-être un peu moins vrai
parce que c'est quand même le même
président va l'armée ne pas dire qu'une
aubaine dont le nucléaire vraiment mais
gardant qu'une valeur à tes jambes et il
ferme fessenheim enfin c'est comme le
président qui comme première action
ferme la centrale nucléaire de
fessenheim est aujourd'hui qu'est ce
qu'on doit faire parce que on n'a plus
l'énergie nucléaire à fessenheim parce
qu'il n'y a aucun projet de construction
qui a été lancé durant son quinquennat
deux centrales nucléaires que soit une
petite ou un e p r on sait
malheureusement la sauce soja il me
semble c'est deux interlocutrices son
projet c'est bien mais ça la réalité des
faits c'était quoi c'était de fermer les
centrales nucléaires il a tout il est
toujours parvenu d'ailleurs sur sa
proposition après avoir fermé fessenheim
de fermer plusieurs tranches de
réacteurs nucléaires dont à côté dans ma
circonscription
gravier et ça fait quoi ça veut dire que
pour aujourd'hui éviter le black out
éviter que on est des coupures
d'électricité une heure par jour en
france on est obligé d'importer de
l'énergie qui a été fabriqué produites
en allemagne à partir à partir de
l'inite qu'on est obligé d'importer du
gaz russe ou qu'on est obligé de en
france rouvrir les centrales à charbon
et augmenter les quotas d'émissions de
co2 on trouvera les centrales à charbon
en france devait les fermer et
finalement on à augmenter les plafonds
d'émissions de gaz de co2 parce que on
n'a pas une stratégie nucléaire en
france alors emmanuel macron commence à
être un converti du nucléaire sur le
tard c'est très bien mais comme emmanuel
macron dit quelque chose est fait à
chaque fois l' inverse excusez moi
d'être un peu sceptique sur ça et je
vous donne un exemple extrêmement
concret règle dans mon territoire du pas
de calais on a on est sous le niveau de
la mer on est dans un bol d'air et parce
que l'énergie coûte beaucoup plus cher
puisqu'on doit l'emporter parce qu'on
n'arrive plus à produire avec l'énergie
qui est propre qui l'énergie nucléaire
qui l'énergie la plus propre et la plus
constante qui peut exister pour évacuer
les eaux qui sont en train d'inonder les
champs on va devoir mettre en place des
générateurs et des des générateurs
diesel donc parce qu'on n'arrive plus à
avoir de l'électricité parce qu emmanuel
macron n'a aucune stratégie à fermer une
centrale nucléaire et ne veut pas
rouvrir d'autres centrales nucléaires on
se retrouve à devoir utiliser du diesel
pour avoir de l'énergie excusez moi je
trouve pas ça très très propre tout en
augmentant les émissions de nos usines
qui sont des usines qui sont alimentés
par du charbon en france on est à l'
inverse complètement de la stratégie
qu'il faut avoir s'enorgueillit alors
répondait justement à ce que vient de
karori du monde on a quand même
l'impression quand même maquereau a fait
choix du nucléaire mais manifestement
peut-être un petit problème dans la
stratégie dans la cohérence
mais si dumont arrive à critiquer macro
main qu'un telle est d'accord avec lui
parce qu'il a la consigne des critiques
et mac rond point barre c'est à dire
c'est simplement c'est tout simplement
bon moi je voudrais vous vous aurez pu
dit pu parler à yannick jadot avant son
intervention passé comme il a fait tout
son temps son intervention contre les
choix nucléaires d'emmanuel macron si
c'est vrai ce que vous dites vous aurez
pu donner d'autres idées à yannick jadot
sont là aussi c'est encore une fois
c'est n'importe quoi aujourd'hui
emmanuel mac on a fait à indiquer
clairement a défendu clairement les
choix nucléaires comme un des éléments
fondamentaux pour réussir dans la
stratégie de neutralité carbone il a
répondu aux critiques d annick jadot et
d'autres sous ses choix il a été très
cohérent et de l'autre pas je voudrais
dire que à la collègue allemande elle
disait que
elle était déçue moi je voudrais lui
demander où elle a été depuis 2009 où
elle était mais elle a été au parlement
européen avec moi je n'ai pas
l'impression ce qui si le pacte vert ce
qu'on appelle les green deal est une
priorité de la commission européenne et
du parlement européen si cela van der
leyen le président de la commission
européenne s'est engagée là dessus c'est
surtout la suite à l'initiative d'
emmanuel macron si pendant la présidence
française de l'union des du conseil de
l'union européenne on va avancer sous
les prix carbone à au
frontières externes de l'union
européenne et c'est grâce justement à
l'action des manuels macron pas ce que
nous voulons faire de la justice
écologique et mettre sur un niveau de
parité nos entreprises européennes qui
sont qui doivent respecter les
obligations d accorder paris les
obligations de transition écologique
nous voulons les mettre sur le même
terrain des jeux qui alors que leurs
concurrents non-européens donc les prêts
carbone aux frontières externes va
exactement dans cette dans sa direction
et c'est un instrument il ressources en
assumant dans la sombre politiques et
les ressources financières fondamental
pour la transition écologique et puis si
on à coopérer même avec les groupes b
des verts peut-être pas avec la colère
hypothèses et ce n'est pas aperçu
maintenant adopter au parlement européen
une stratégie pour rendre les marchés
unique durable est compatible avec la
transition écologique et la france a
aussi soutenu stratégique à la france a
aussi soutenu soutenu dans lesquels je
travaillais très bien avec son collègue
david cormont je ne sais pas si la
députée franco-allemandes sont aperçus
que nous des règnes ou les maquereaux
nice ont très bien travaillé là dessus
et donc on est honnêtement si on veut
continuer avec la propagande si jade
aujourd'hui on peut continuer si on veut
parler du sérieux de l'engagement des
macros on peut rappeler aussi que
l'accord de marc marc sourd a été
suspendu n'a pas été signé justement
parce que bon son art au brésil ne vaut
pas s'engager sur les engagements de
transition écologique sur les accords de
paris sur le respect de la vie des
sociétés et ça aussi ça a été à
l'initiative d'emmanuel macron donc j'ai
beau projet je vaux bien que et s'est
dit déçu peut-être et ce n'est pas
aperçu de ce qui s'est passé depuis 2019
halak départ n'est greenberg vous
répondez très vite sur cette question
juste à ce que vient de dire sandro gozi
vous ne vous êtes pas aperçu que en fait
y avait quand même un green deal dans
l'est que tout le monde se plaît en
europe rapidement parce que je veux
qu'on passe aux valeurs c'est très
simple de dire aux autres qu'ils dorment
je suis entre en commission de transport
et en commission agriculture je sais
très bien ce qui a été fait pas je suis
tous les dossiers du fit forfait stefan
ne vous inquiétez pas je suis bien
réveillé il ne s'agit pas de critiquer
tout noir ou tout blanc ce que fait
monsieur mâcon ce n'est absolument pas
mon intérêt ce n'est pas si intéressant
que ça je suis désolé d'un point de vue
européen oui il ya des choses
excellentes qui ont été faits par
l'union européenne et aussi bien sûr
avec les états membres dont la france et
je suis très fier aussi que nous mettons
en avant les le sibac donc
aux frontières tout ce qui est le et tcs
je suis très pour ça mais on a oublié
complètement l'agriculture on n'a pas
entendu parler aujourd'hui il faut le
dire alors qu'elle est vraiment aussi la
source de beaucoup de problème pas
seulement au niveau climatique mais
aussi au niveau des sols et de l'air et
vous le savez aussi pour les paysans
c'est difficile on n'a pas du tout mis
en avant bien sûr tout ce qu'il fallait
aussi changé par rapport à notre
politique des deux de commerce extérieur
qui aussi pour rejoindre le début pour
rejoindre au début les experts les idées
migratoires on n'a pas parlé aujourd'hui
comment changer non politique alors je
ne veux pas seulement dire du pour et du
contre de monsieur ma course c'est
inintéressant il faut parler des vrais
thèmes et moi je pense que la transition
énergétique là la france est en train de
faire une erreur en se bloquant tous on
voit bien quasiment tous les partis sur
le nucléaire alors que ce n'est pas
l'avenir
ça nuit à l'adie la biodiversité à long
terme et voilà être décarbonés mais
c'est très cher et services doit bien on
voit bien les deux visions antinomiques
j'aimerais qu'on parle des valeurs on va
écouter macro emmanuel macron qui a
parlé d'une europe puissante et
démocratique et voilà ce qu'ils disent
sur la pologne et la hongrie
moi je suis surpris qu'on reproche à qui
que ce soit et d'ailleurs plusieurs
lancers de signer des textes sur des
sujets qu'ils soient sociaux qu'ils
soient environnementaux énergétiques
avec des pays comme la pologne et la
hongrie
dans ces cas-là fait arrêtez arrêtez
l'union européenne tout de suite aux
excuses c'est pas possible nous pouvons
avoir un dialogue des désaccords et les
assumer mais il est tout à fait légitime
y compris dans le cadre de désaccord de
principe que nous avons avec certains
pays de continuer à avancer sur le reste
de l'agenda c'est le fonctionnement même
de notre europe est revenue vers la
pologne et la hongrie en menaçant état
de droit devrait-elle quitter l'europe
non je ne sais pas si la colonie la
hongrie menace l'état de droit je crois
au gouvernement des juges c'est une
suspension de la démocratie et à cet
égard devrions avoir une oreille
fricoter ce que nous disent les polonais
les hongrois probablement emmanuel
macron à travers ses derniers voyages
ces derniers contacts art en effet
l'oreille fine parce que je crois qu'il
ya une chose que nous devons entendre et
que les pays de l'est qui ont résisté
aux ou soviétique d'outils ce que
quelqu'un comme milan kundera dit très
bien à l'est on a conservé sa liberté
par son air conserver sa culture sa
langue ses moeurs et sa foi alors qu'à
l'ouest pourquoi qu'on va gagner la
liberté en rejetant par dessus les murs
je pense et si c'est le cas c'est
emmanuel macron a entendu ce qui nous
vient de l'est qui je crois la vraie
liberté la vraie liberté c'est pour
atteindre leur est demandé eh bien je
pense que ce serait une avancée
importante pour un neurone pn parce que
là réellement on pourrait conclure que
l'union européenne est riche de la
diversité des nations qui la composent
devrions réviser fortement ce que nous
entendons par l'état de droit qui
aboutit à une uniformisation contre
l'identité constitutionnelle des peuples
et contre la liberté de chaque nation a
décidé elle-même de son destin pierre
henri dumont vous êtes d'accord une
procédure il faut le rappeler un contre
la hongrie une procédure européenne
justement parce qu'il ya les atteintes à
l'état de droit mon millan cruz nairas
c'est pas tout à fait viktor orban votre
votre opinion à ce que effectivement
elle devrait quitter l'europe la pologne
et la honte non façon à partir du moment
où on est une europe à 27 aujourd'hui il
faut prendre chaque pays avec ses
spécificités on peut pas demander à des
pays d'avoir le même cheminement quand
ils ont vécu sous le joug soviétique que
des pays d'europe de l'ouest qui n'ont
pas connu d'occupation depuis la fin de
la seconde guerre mondiale donc il faut
respecter je pense chaque pays et en
cela je pense que nous devons continuer
à travailler sur l'intégration des pays
qui n'a toujours pas été digéré suite au
grand élargissement du début des années
2000 plutôt que de vouloir écarter
balles et les dix pays qui sont rentrés
plus croatie on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui
ce feriez pour un élargissement sait
absolument pas ce que je vous ai dit je
vous dis au contraire on doit continuer
à travailler sur le
l'equilibre des niveaux de vie par
exemple de salaires en termes de droit
social en termes de droits des femmes
l'égalité hommes-femmes et c'est entre
ces pays qui dont l'intégration n'a pas
encore été je pense totalement digérée
par l'union européenne avant de vouloir
comme le veut et emmanuel macron
continuer à élargir l'union européenne
et c'est pour ça que nous nous sommes
totalement contre l'élargissement de
l'union européenne qui était annoncé par
emmanuel macron lors de son discours à
strasbourg en particulier aux balkans
occidentaux et une fois plus je rappelle
que la turquie elle n'a aucune vocation
à rentrer quel que soit le jour dans
l'union européenne et qu'on doit vous
êtes d'accord on va mettre un terme
emmanuel macron il est dans le même
temps enfin pardon mais il continue les
discussions d'adhésion de la turquie
alors qu'il dit qu'ils doivent pas
rentrer dans ces cas-là arrêtant les
discussions d'adhésion mettons un terme
à ces discussions et admettons enfin que
la turquie n'a pas vocation à entrer
dans l'europe et valère minerai papa
peut-être par une petite chose qu'on n'a
plus le temps bon voilà on a vu un petit
peu ce qu'étaient les clivages justement
au sein de cette campagne française
campagne présidentielle française ces
clivages autour de la question
européenne ont bien sûr on continuera
d'en parler sur notre antenne merci
pierre henri dumont le temps était trop
court merci à vous sandro gozi hervé
juvin anna départ année greenberg merci
d'avoir été avec ton direct de
strasbourg merci à vous tous de nous
avoir suivis reste avec nous sur france
[Musique]